what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with invincible specifically
we're here at the end of invincible
there is no more invincible after this
we are completely and totally done now
what i'm probably gonna do here is i'm
gonna make a full story out of this and
i'm gonna throw it up on patreon but i
am god i am so hyped about this because
this story god the ending is so good
with this whole thing so in the last
video we basically covered how it was
like the final war right the forces of
freddie mercury and like all the
children that he had basically created
it's kind of a quote unquote new
viltrumide empire as well as like the
forces of earth and the coalition of
planets i mean it's the big hullabaloo
right like it's the big thing
everything's been leading up to this and
that at the end of that video freddie
mercury had basically ripped nolan in
half right like he had seemingly killed
nolan and so what happens is that with
adam eve watching all this unfold she
basically ends up creating a kind of a
bubble around herself right a force
field flies into space grabs nolan and
then brings him back now the hope here
is that nolan can basically be saved but
we're not definitively sure if that's
the case what we also end up getting
here is a little bit of things turning
around in the sense that where rex robot
had very much been an enemy of mark that
he does appear here on the scene now one
thing to know mark does go and try to
fight freddie mercury but the reality is
that he's just no match for him right
he's just not on the same level as
freddie mercury in this in this this bit
of a conflict here and so what ends up
happening is when rex robot shows up
this is when things really start to get
crazy because what rex says is look like
i know we're not the best of friends and
i know that we're technically enemies
but there's no reason that we can't
simply work together to take out a
mutual enemy because as we know the
intention of thrag here right the
intention of freddie mercury is to wipe
out earth's superheroes and then
basically destroy what's left of the
vulture might race because he doesn't
really see them as being true
viltromites anymore he's basically
looking to form his own empire of sorts
and essentially go from there and so
following that it basically turns into
mark and and uh freddie mercury kind of
a round two right where the two of them
literally just start going to blows with
one another now one of the things that
happens and this is exceedingly
important here one of the things that
freddie mercury says and he doesn't
really care who hears he talks about the
nature of his children and he says like
they're cannon fodder that's all they
are i can have more of them in a minute
right like assuming they if they were to
all die here it wouldn't make any
difference i would go right back to my
home base those people on that planet
worship me as a god i can just start
procreating again and in a matter of
like a year or so my numbers will be
right back to where they were before or
at least very close to it right and so
ultimately he doesn't really see his
children as being anything meaningful
the reason why this matters is because
if you guys recall in the last video
that we talked about one of the
daughters of freddie mercury the one
that kind of stood out the most that
while her brother and the son of freddie
mercury had been killed freddie mercury
didn't really care much about the death
of his son at that point he just kind of
saw him as a death right like that was
it and there was another soldier to
replace him that combined with the fact
that one of the other other children
said that if they were to die in battle
against the forces of earth or whoever
then maybe freddie mercury would know
their name like literally for them dying
would mean they would gain the honor of
their father recognizing their very
existence and so this in a lot of ways
had started to turn the views of freddie
mercury's daughter where she started to
realize how little he cares about them
and so what ends up happening is that at
this point mark and everybody like
market freddie mercury just throw
caution in the window and they just
start fighting in the most brutal way
ever right like literally mark flies
them to the sun and the two of them just
start fighting inside the sun while all
that's going on the daughter of freddie
mercury is like enough right this has
gone on long enough like i'm just
watching my brothers and sisters just
die constantly in the name of a father
who cares nothing about them and so she
ultimately calls a ceasefire and is like
everyone stop and then just says we
surrender like we're done like we're not
fighting for freddie mercury anymore we
basically give up and they hand
themselves over to the uh to the forces
of the coalition of worlds to allen the
alien and so at this point we switch
over to the fight between freddie
mercury and mark now this is a hugely
significant battle between the two one
because it's a long time coming but two
their their their motivation for
fighting comes from two distinctly
different places when mark asked the
question what are you trying to
accomplish here like literally what it
is that you've done is you've brought
all your forces here and you're watching
members of your vilture might race die
the response of freddie mercury is it's
revenge i don't care about them they
cast me out they don't matter to me
anymore right they are weak they are
pathetic they allied themselves with
humans on earth and they're forming
families right like what even is this
and at that point it's just kind of like
they're nothing to me anymore they are
not my realtor my brothers and sisters
they're not my people right they chose
their side and now i'm choosing mine and
ultimately he's kind of like you and all
the other vulture mites will be erased
from history and that will be it now one
thing i want to point out here is they
are not immune to the effects of the sun
right this this whole thing going on
with them right the sun impacting them
burning their clothes away and then
burning you know eventually burning
their skin away this is literally just
what's happening right like they're not
immune to that level of heat they're
highly durable but they're not
indestructible but the important thing
that goes on here right the important
thing behind all of this is that in the
end what mark says once the communicator
basically burns out and the two of them
can't necessarily talk to each other
anymore that mark kind of has like an
inner monologue right where he knows
that freddie mercury can't hear him but
he still kind of talks and what he says
is like the big difference between the
two is that in the end freddie mercury
only fights for himself that's all it is
right he only fights for himself because
in his mind he's the rightful heir of
the viltrumide empire and his mind while
technically nolan and mark are are the
sons of argol meaning as far as the
bloodline goes they're the rightful
heirs it was freddie mercury who stood
in when argol was killed it was freddie
mercury that led the vulture might race
to where they were it was freddie
mercury who basically kind of kept the
entire thing going and quote unquote
made them stronger by weeding out the
weak he's the one that did all of that
right he basically kept the house taken
care of you know in the absence of nolan
in the absence of mark albeit no one
knew that they were the the rightful
heirs until eventually freddie mercury
found out and then killed the scientists
and all that kind of stuff you know we
talked about that but nonetheless the
response of mark and what actually
happens here is rex robot sends one of
his drones a kind of armor that encases
mark and protects mark temporarily from
the effects of the sun so he can fight a
little bit longer in this battle against
freddie mercury and that's what mark
says that's how we're different you see
yourself as this kind of end-all be-all
all-encompassing being that is the sole
leader of the vulture might race the one
person who can basically overcome all
but in the end when the dust settles
right when the lights go out you've got
no one in your corner there's no one
cheering or cheering you on there's no
one backing you i mean sure you have
like the kids that you've created but
they're soldiers right they would die
for you but they don't die for you out
of love and out of loyalty they die for
you in the pursuit of gaining some
measure of your affection and because
you told them to but you have no true
friends you have nobody in your corner
no one is sending a suit of armor to
save you here no one is doing what
they're doing for me that's the
difference between us and that's what
mark says that is what inherently makes
us stronger and this is a true statement
right it's an accurate statement to make
that that for so long and even for
myself as an individual for so long you
just you kind of get used to being alone
that after a while when you're suddenly
introduced to this idea that like you're
better off having other people in your
side that it almost seems foreign to you
it seems strange and it seems like it's
not the way that it's supposed to be and
the result of this is that freddie
mercury never accepted that but mark did
right mark was like i've got people in
my corner i've got people watching my
back i fight for something greater than
myself right he says you value and
respect only strength you feel only the
strong deserve to live you cling to
practices that pushed our people to the
brink of extinction you see us as people
living only for conquest measured only
by the size of our empire no room for
peace no room for compassion no room for
love and he says you thought you were
keeping the empire alive pulling us back
from the brink of extinction the truth
is that you were holding us back under
your leadership the viltrumites stood
for nothing they fought for nothing just
like you and that while the fight rages
on it while it continues to go on and on
and on and on in the end mark manages to
get the upper hand and manages to at the
very least incapacitate freddie mercury
and as that happens he begins to succumb
to the power of the sun and then alan
the alien swoops in out of nowhere saves
mark and flies away and freddie mercury
is just left to dissolve in the sun and
that's it now once mark gets back to the
medical ship we can call that i mean the
guy's a crispy critter right let me
either fight in the sun right what do
you expect he's been fighting the sun
the guy the guy's a
guy is
he is the most burnt chicken nugget ever
seen in your life and adam eve of course
is sad about that but as we know they
have ways of healing people from all
this kind of stuff right bringing them
back from all those things and so you do
have this bit of a temporary meeting
that takes place between allen alien and
the daughter of uh of freddie mercury
and this is kind of a cool little thing
here because as the two of them are
talking and as the two of them are
having a conversation when ursula is
just kind of like look you know we we
did terrible things we killed in the
name of our father because that's what
we thought we were supposed to do you
know we can never really be redeemed for
that so we are essentially handing
ourselves over to to whatever it is that
the uh the coalition of worlds will will
do with us and the response of of uh
alan alien here is did your father ever
teach your teacher people about the
concept of forgiveness because the
reality here is they're as much victims
of their father as anybody else's right
if they were raised by their dad and all
they were taught was your job is to die
and to kill whoever it is that i tell
you to they never had a chance it's not
as though there's some race that existed
out there that knew the difference
between right and wrong and that they
chose the side of freddie mercury and
now they got to pay the price they were
conditioned to believe what they believe
they never had a chance to believe
otherwise so giving them the opportunity
of forgiveness is to say you can be
redeemed now if they waste it
if they buy their time and decide to
destroy the coalition of worlds well
then you know whatever happens happens
but it's the chance to you know giving
them the the opportunity to redeem
themselves that ability that offering of
redemption that's what differentiates us
that's what makes people great often
times we don't see that oftentimes we
look at another person or another thing
and we say that harmed us screw it right
and you just walk away forever but the
ability to to offer that measure of
self-sacrifice and to say redemption can
be found here now if you dick me over
twice then then we cut all ties but
having that measure of redemption that's
what differentiates the good guys from
the bad guys now as far as mark goes in
the interim while he's healing the guy
looks like a borg not even gonna lie but
when he asks the question how is nolan
doing right how's my dad doing can i see
him adam eve looks pretty sad and the
reason why is because once mark goes to
see his father nolan's basically dying
that you would expect nolan to be able
to survive that due to the various forms
of medical treatment but what he says is
that in the end his heart just wasn't
strong enough to keep him alive right he
says i was able to dodge the brunt of
thrag's attack but not enough he says
because of my damaged heart my body's
not strong enough to repair itself
there's no coming back from nolan now
this is an exceedingly important thing
here and if anything this truly reveals
how much nolan has changed because if
you guys recall at the beginning of
invincible he was going to conquer the
world in the name of the vulture might
race and he damn near beat his son to
death ultimately stopping himself and
then fleeing what he says here is that
everything he's done from the time that
he became the emperor until now was to
lead the people of the vulture might
race into a better future and he says
it's your time now mark right i am
passing on that means that the role of
emperor now falls to you and it's your
job to lead the viltrumite race and when
mark says but i don't want to like the
thing that nolan says is you have to
remember like you can't leave here i
mean you you can you can leave and you
can go to some other part of the
universe and you and adam eve and and
your daughter you all can have like that
that quiet peaceful life that you've
always wanted but where will you go
right what will you do do you think
there's any place out there where you'll
be safe and if so for how long and what
will you be doing that won't simply be
hiding from your responsibilities and he
says and before you answer think about
what it will mean to be in control of
the vulture might empire and what kind
of world you could build for your
daughter this is a hugely important
thing because what nolan is saying here
is you are the rightful heir of the
vulture might race whether you accept it
or not it is your responsibility but if
you are in charge of the viltrumite race
look at what they did as a race that was
used for destruction for conquest
imagine what they could be if they were
a race that was built for peace if they
were a race that was built for doing
something great no one says i am a
better person because of you i need you
to know that son i need you to know i
became better because of you and he says
i was born of our people their ways
their ways were brutal and they were
savage they were barbaric that is
present in all of our kind it's what
leads them to make mistakes they can
slip up they can slide back into the old
ways just like anissa did you were free
from that you were always on a different
path you can show us a better way and
that's where nolan ultimately passes
away right that's where he basically he
passes away but the last thing he says
to mark is you changed me you can change
them and that's where mark basically it
really kind of of dawns on him right
once his father passes on once his
father dies then he realizes that yes
that is true the entire vulture might
race had been used as a race of conquest
they've been bred for conquest right
that like weeding out the weak to only
keep the strong that it turned them into
the spartans of the invincible universe
right they were capable of fighting and
not much else instead what he says is we
can make them better we can turn them
into something else adam eve is not
readily on in support of that right
instead she's just kind of like no i
want us to be able to do our own thing
to kind of have our own life but mark's
like no this is my responsibility this
is my role as the leader of the villager
my race this is part of what it means to
make a life with me this is not
something we can run away from and so if
this is something you feel like you
cannot do then it means as heartbreaking
as it is we will have to part ways but
my duty is to a greater thing because
being in control of the vulture might
race does not mean just sitting on earth
and making sure that they bang and they
have kids so the numbers can increase it
means we can use the vulture might race
to bring peace to a universe in a way
that the coalition of worlds simply just
can't do and so what ends up following
here and this is what's really
interesting kind of a small little
skirmish it really is sort of uh of
kirkman wrapping things up with with rex
right just kind of being like okay so
like rex is still in control of the
earth
what really just kind of goes on here is
that rex robot steps up and because he
had previously taken the kids of the
viltromites when the vulture mites were
going off to fight in space under the
guise that like the kids were going to
be protected the reality is he was going
to use them as ransom that what happens
is that once those kids are under the
hands of rex robot he injures the other
vulture mites and says kill mark right
destroy those guys if you don't i will
destroy your children and so the vulture
might of course end up turning on the
coalition of worlds and end up turning
uh turning against mark and there is a
kind of fight here now the reason why
i'm kind of glossing over this is
because what happens is mark actually
goes to the vulture mites and says make
him believe that you're fighting on my
side because here's what's gonna happen
once this is done he's gonna know he has
you under your under his thumb once he
knows he can make you do anything that
you want as long as he's in control of
your kids he'll never let your kids go
because the instant he does now he has
no control over you like rex is no
different from cecil cecil operated the
exact same way so he's like put on a
show make it look good and then in the
end we'll make our move and we'll come
out on top and that's exactly what
happens right once they're able to track
down the location of where the where the
actual rex is among all those forces
they immediately attack and subdue him
right now mark of course ends up going
into space and having a bit of a
conversation with rex but ultimately
what he says is is like we're not going
anywhere and this whole thing that you
have this whole thing that you're doing
here it's not going to work the reason
why is yes you've made the world a
better place yes you've improved on
things when the question is asked by rex
like you see what your father saw right
like you are your father's son after all
no matter how much you try to fight it
you see the difference i've made in this
world you recognize the positive effect
i've had i'm smarter than it's possible
to give me credit for i can see you
thinking you recognizing the good i've
done but i still fear the bad i could
potentially do you're racking your brain
trying to think of a way that you can
keep one and lose the other aren't you
and mark says yes and i think i figured
it out mark kills rex robot on the spot
punches a hole through him and then
after everything is all said and done he
meets with the immortal and what he says
is everything that rex has done in terms
of unifying the world governments and
creating a kind of lasting peace that's
that's what needed to happen right i
couldn't see it at the time but what he
was doing was a good thing what he was
doing was bringing peace to the world
the problem is rex himself couldn't be
trusted to maintain that peace had it
gone on any longer he would have become
some kind of crazy fascist dictator it
was only a matter of time you saw the
signs i saw the signs we all saw the
signs and so what he says is you
immortal you you have what rex didn't
have rex had knowledge he had his
experience leading you know the the
thraxions and all those guys he says you
have the thing that rex didn't have
you've got a moral conscience and two
you have wisdom because you've been
around for an exceedingly long amount of
time and the fact that immortal
initially is like i can't really argue
with your logic but i don't know if i'm
up to the task that right there tells
mark everything he needs to know that a
person who leads even albeit reluctantly
is a person who may be the best person
suited for that job it's not an absolute
rule right some people who are reluctant
to lead they feel that way because they
really are incompetent and once they're
put into that position of leadership
they become every bit as incompetent as
you thought they were and they basically
screw stuff up but in this case immortal
is a guy who could legitimately lead as
far as uh as far as rex goes because he
does have knowledge that they need they
ultimately strip him down to his bare
components right literally a brain
hooked up to like a machine that can
communicate and that's it but it can't
activate any of the robots or anything
like that it's just a source of
knowledge and nothing more the other
part of this is that mark and the rest
of the viltrumites ultimately end up
leaving the world now here's one of the
things that comes out of this this is
one of the significant moments here is
that you do have this realization as far
as mark is concerned that he has a son
now for those of you guys who recall the
last video that we did what we said is
that when anissa had sexually assaulted
mark and got herself pregnant that she
succeeded in that but mark never knew
that he had a son but following anissa's
death somebody has to be there to raise
this child somebody has to be there to
take care of him and that one where mark
himself ends up stepping up after this
kid kind of loses his mind and starts
attacking the city not fully realizing
what he's capable of and so on and so
forth that mark has a conversation with
him march starts talking to him and says
yes like i'm your biological father i am
one half of of your genealogy that you
your mother and i had basically been
together even though it was against my
will and this led to you but something
that you have to understand is you have
an incredible level of power and you
have to learn how to harness that power
you have to learn what it is that you're
capable of and so what ends up happening
is that where the offer is is extended
to both the family the the the adoptive
father of mark the guy who was married
to anissa and then like mark himself and
the rest of the family and whatnot the
response to the adopted father is we're
not going anywhere we're gonna stay here
on this earth and i'm going to raise him
here and ultimately mark ends up siding
with it and the reason why is because
from his perspective it really is the
best thing to do right where he tells
his his son essentially the history of
the viltrumites what they had done the
kind of things that they had been
involved in mark in a lot of ways sees
himself in this child and what he
realizes is that had there been some
instance reflecting back on the
different alternate reality versions of
himself that he had seen one of which
had been taken by his father and raised
in the viltrum right ways and then
returned to conquer the world where he
sees that as a possibility looking at
his own experience he became the person
he was because he stayed on earth
because he lived among just regular
people none of which had any power that
provided him with a sort of compass and
a world view that he wouldn't be able to
get otherwise and the result of this is
he essentially ends up siding with uh
with the father with the adoptive father
and saying yeah let him stay here right
it worked for me it can work for him but
if he ever wants to visit we're only
ever one one vessel away right he can
come and see us and and we can kind of
hang out and we can do our thing of
course following that you end up having
mark's mom who basically takes uh takes
the son to essentially go see the tailor
the guy that creates a suit for him he
kind of becomes invincible junior to a
degree and then meets like the newest
iteration of uh of what you could argue
the guardians of the globe or the teen
team but whatever it is the newest
iteration of the superhero team that
exists out there fights alongside them
you know and and it's basically kind of
making a way for himself right sort of
carving out a bit of this for himself
now there are a couple of things that
that kirkman left open all the potential
he could build on it at a future point
in time if he ever wanted to come out a
really good example of this is what
looks like the son of angstrom levy that
essentially he is here as a result of
the actions of mark in erasing the
actual angstrom levy from the timeline
right like he literally says uh dad's
not going to be here either he's been
erased from the multiverse there's
simply just none of him left right now
we know that because angstrom levy was
destroyed right he's he was absolutely
eradicated but it means his son could
end up taking up his mantle now this is
where things also get kind of
interesting because following that we
get a couple little time skips here
nothing overly huge but for for mark's
daughter
[Laughter]
for mark's daughter he ends up having to
go through daughter things which of
course is her just kind of being like
you know it's not fair right you know i
can take care of these little puppies
you know and mark's like you're not
ready for a dog right so like she wants
an animal uh and then of course she gets
a costume where she can fight but she
thinks the uniform sucks you know that
like uh that like her brother marcus had
like broken broken one of her belongings
when they were on earth you know that
kind of a thing that there was some
alien race that had done something i
guess they had attacked some people and
they had done it out of hunger or
whatever it is there's the big bomb
where mark catches his daughter with
another guy
where she's sneaking boys into the house
you know like literally he's like you're
my daughter right i'm the emperor of our
people we have to set a better example
tara that boy was beneath you and she's
like and beside me and on top of me and
behind me right just kind of it's like
damn terrible she's this girl's a freak
having that hot girl summer
and then of course as is usually the
case she grows out of that phase and
then grows into becoming like an adult
that kind of moves on and just starts
focusing on trying to become the best
version of herself and even becomes a
bit of a superhero to a degree and so
one of the things that's kind of cool
here and what's really really
interesting is there is a point where a
war breaks out between the forces of the
viltromites basically between the forces
of mark and the coalition of planets and
the reason why is it's 100 politics what
happens here is mark is called to a
meeting by alan the alien and what alan
alien basically says is your people are
doing too good of a job traveling around
the universe and ending conflicts right
you're literally destroying
dictatorships you're getting rid of all
these evil forces and you're bringing
peace to the universe the problem with
that is you're basically making the
coalition of planets an unnecessary
concept there are people who are leaving
but my job is to keep the coalition
together so in effect you are making me
obsolete that's a problem and as a
result of that a war breaks out between
the two now it's one of those things
where the war is essentially won by the
vulture mites there's not really a whole
lot that the the coalition of worlds can
do and the response of mark is look if
this is the way things are if my force
is bringing peace to the universe makes
the coalition of worlds obsolete then
let it fade away the coalition of worlds
was a response to a chaotic time that
you had the viltromites who were running
around the universe they were conquering
worlds and they needed to unify in order
to defeat that common threat what you're
doing here is you're holding on to the
past you're holding on to the way things
used to be you're not moving forward and
you're not progressing if there is no
need for the coalition of worlds then
let the coalition of worlds die right if
it doesn't have to exist then stop
trying to save it and so that's why you
just kind of like all you had to do was
come and talk to me you didn't have to
start a war you didn't have to initiate
a conflict between us but the reality is
we are not going to stop trying to make
the universe a better place either you
can accept that and help us become more
of a humanitarian group as opposed to a
military-based group designed for
defense uh or this war can keep going
and we can bring to ruin everything that
you know and everything you understand
now the other part of this is remember
because tara is one half vulture might
as well as mark being one half village
right which i imagine terra is actually
more one-quarter villager mine she has
an enhanced longevity right her and mark
will basically outlive adam eve and
that's exactly what happens as the years
pass and time goes on adam eve gets
older and older and older until she
ultimately ends up passing away and then
she comes
back then apparently she is actually
immortal she dies of old age and then
boom powers reactivate and then she
basically just reverts back into her
younger self which is kind of cool
because it means they can essentially
stay together forever which is kind of
awesome but that's the thing right over
time and that's why i say we kind of get
this time skip right that's flashing
forward that over time one of the things
that the the vulture might do is they
bring an end to civil wars like blood
feuds that have been been happening over
planets they bring resources and they
bring the way uh bring waste to grow
crops and things like that in order to
allow planets that are otherwise arid or
barren to flourish how that focuses on
the idea of you know a planet being
unable to flourish because it's like too
close to the sun so it'll always be arid
and barren i don't really know i assume
they move the inhabitants to a different
world but the thing about this is that
it really is them just making the world
a better place just improving on the
world and seemingly everywhere they can
it's a lot of politics and it's a lot of
of kind of going back and forth but at
the end of the day the task and really
the thing that nolan had set mark out to
achieve which is to make the universe
better to lead the viltromites into a
future where they can be a humanitarian
and even save your race as opposed to a
race of conquest it all comes true and
so when what is probably the single
greatest achievement of mark at the end
of all of this when he's there with adam
eve and he's there with his daughter and
they're spending time together uh the
single greatest achievement of mark is
that he was somehow able to make himself
look like shazam from the 1940s with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this video to an end
this is the end of invincible and what a
story it was right happily ever after
it's good to see that they all actually
came out on top but we're going to bring
this to an end if you guys want to see
the full story make sure you check out
patreon and i will check you all or i
will i will check you all i will check
your cells before you wreck yourself i
will catch you all later
peace